The answer is $900. Great work if you figured that one out. We know in our first
case we work 35 hours and we earn $630. For the second case we're going to work
50 hours but we don't know how much money we're going to get. So we'll use x for
that income two. Next we want to multiply both sides of our equation by the
lowest common denominator or 50 times x. So we'll be left with 35 times x on the
left and 630 times 50 on the right. Essentially when we do this we cross
multiply. We'll have x time 35 here, and 50 times 630 here. Finally, we divide
both sides by 35, and we get x is equal to 900. When you're problem solving, you
want to make sense of this number in the end. What were we solving for? Well we
were wondering how much we could make, so that means we made $900. I know I
included the unit here for you, but make sure you do that in your own problem
solving and throughout the rest of your work.